following our american profile
conversations it's some of the week's
top political events beginning with a
speech by president bill clinton at 10
am
following that at 11 05 a.m we'll take
you to a republican news conference
addressing the president's economic plan
all ahead this morning on c-span
[Music]
next on c-span an american profile
conversation with former u.s
representative shirley chisholm
just before the democratic national
convention last summer we spoke with ms
chisholm in 1972 the new york democrat
became the first black woman to seek the
presidency
in this conversation she shares her
thoughts about the 1992 presidential
election and reflects on her own
campaign for president
c-span's american profile series
highlights the lives and careers of
political and business leaders the
program aims to provide our viewers with
a better understanding of the individual
behind the public persona
[Music]
shirley chisholm how do you explain this
incredible presidential year
i think i can explain in terms of the
fact that we've certainly gotten to a
point in american history now
where the american people
feel
a kind of alienation and cynicism
from traditional politics as we have
known it when we are addressing the
selection of a person to guide the ship
of state for four year period i.e the
president
the people
feel that whether democrats or
republicans
that is all part of the same old
traditional package
that there needs to be change in america
and that if the change does not emanate
from the programs in the gender and the
plans of either one of the two parties
americans have gotten to the point where
they are willing
to make that change outside
of the regular two-party structure but
how do you think we got to that point
and i ask you because you've been
involved in politics for a long time
including your own run for president
which we'll talk about later but what is
it that got us to that point how did the
parties get disconnected from the people
i think there's a combination of factors
uh
first of all the parties uh have not
been able
to be
patronage dispensers particularly on the
local and state levels particularly on
those levels
many of the club houses in the district
local offices pertaining to partisan
parties are no longer in the communities
across this nation
uh it seems to me that
people became very disinterested as a
result of a series of cumulative
experiences in this country that turned
them all
korea gate after watergate and then
during the past 12 years the fantastic
national scandals
that came about the snl situation and
the situation which we're still
discussing pertaining to the iran contra
herrings
people are really fed up so we've gotten
to the point where they are not really
holding on
to
following persons necessarily in either
one of the two parties in other words
they're saying parenthetically enough is
enough we are willing now at this point
in the year 1992
to really do something to bring about it
they're fed up as i travel throughout
the country in the farm communities the
rural communities the inner city areas
uh you find people saying the same thing
over and over again
in different terms
we're fed up we don't ask me about
issues i'm never trusting we want
somebody's going to bring about change
that's the most important word now that
you hear constantly everybody
is talking
about
change do you think that that is that
your explanation for the appeal of ross
perot yes i think it's part is part of
the appeal they see ross perot
as a man
who is a billionaire
and who has kept very close to his own
breasts what he stands for what his
overall agenda is but all they know is
from the little bit that they have heard
is that he has been a man of action he
doesn't talk a whole lot he gets things
done he's an activist and the american
people have become or are becoming sick
and tired of the same political rhetoric
every four years from both parties only
to find that when either one of the two
parties finally lands in the white house
that nothing really changes and so they
are willing this time out
to really even follow a ross perot if
they have to because they know that
their quality of life has deteriorated
so badly that he couldn't be possibly
any worse in terms of responding to
their needs than either one of the
individual two parties strange
phenomenon
you grew up in the democratic party do
you think it's going to survive this
election cycle well the democratic party
will survive it will be uh and what may
really survive but i'm quite sure that
it is going to survive but i also sense
a
growing growing disenchantment with the
parties to the extent that we may have
in the very near future the
establishment of a third party in this
country not based on race however but
will be based on class uh when you go
out into the farm community so it's
amazing to hear the farmers tell you you
know they'll say to me mrs it's time for
a third party you know farmers they have
been loyal uh to their republican party
or to the democratic party these are not
the people who usually go off in other
directions that you will try to
try that you could never think of the
farmers in this country as being of a
radical nature if that's the term you
desire to use but now they're so fed up
the the people being fed up and i sense
this all over the country so i see the
possibility of a third party uh evolving
sometimes within the next six to eight
years i won't be the least a bit
surprised
are americans ideological do you think
or do they just want
things to get done i don't think
americans are are basically ideological
i really believe that they
want to get things done they have seen
their tax paying dollars being utilized
for all kinds of uh aid foreign aid
programs abroad they have been waiting
on this peace dividend because it was
promised to them that when the war in
the gulf was over that we will use the
money now to rebuild our cities and our
towns and our villages and all of it has
been nothing but
rhetoric and so now
the they are willing now to say
we would like to get a change
can you imagine people getting to the
point where they don't even know what
the candidate really stands for this is
very what what is his agenda and very
educated people i have met black and
white they've said to me straight i
don't care what mr perot stands for i'm
not interested he's a man of action i
think that's very dangerous when people
in this country get to the point that
they're not really interested in what
the gentleman or the candidate's overall
agenda is is because they're fed up
well let's uh go back here we are the
20th anniversary of your own race for
president in 1972.
what what thinking did you have when you
announced for president and how was it
received
then in the first place
my announcement for president was made
on the basis of two states in the union
the people
told me
mrs chisholm
we've again it's interesting we've got
to have some change in government
the time has come when we have to move
in the direction
of hoping that someday somewhere somehow
a black man
or a woman can be president
a black person rather a woman can be
president
mrs tisson
you have
a knowledge of the issues you're
bilingual
you articulate well
you're not phony
you become a catalyst that's how it all
developed in the states of florida and
minnesota those two states and at that
time in 1972 florida had less than a ten
percent black population and minnesota
had only about a three percent black
population why those two states i i had
been doing some
public speaking
and you know when i emerged in this
country everybody wanted to know who
shirley jason was who was this black
woman that was going to be the first
person of her sex and of her race to
enter the united states house of
representatives and so i did a lot of
speaking and they found out that i was
fairly intelligent
fearless had a knowledge of issues not
afraid and they said we
desire that you begin to help bring
about some change in america and i was
oh i was afraid because i remember
saying to them you don't run for the
presidency of this country on the basis
of
a moral feeling or moral commitment you
need money and i didn't ask for money
but amazingly within three months time
the state of florida and the state of
minnesota raised ten thousand dollars
each
then they could hold my blood i got
frightened when they called and said we
have raised money and i wanted to back
out
i became afraid because i never believed
that this would have happened
and it happened and then i had to make
my mind up
and once i said no you can't go back
you threw out a kind of indirect
challenge to them
and you can't do this for people so i
made my mind up then that i was going to
make the bid and all hell broke loose
when i announced i was going to run for
president where did you announce and to
whom i announced
at the concord
street baptist church in brooklyn new
york in the midst of my congressional
district which was the 12th
congressional district
and i announced to the people of the
community and a number of friends that
were aware of my announcement and came
in uh from cities particularly along the
eastern seaboard the church was jammed
there must be close to two thousand
people and the excitement that was there
and
all of the enthusiasm that was there
that a black
woman for the first time
in the united states of america
had the audacity and the nerve to say
she wanted to guide the ship of state
she wanted to be president
and i could remember i could see the
picture now it was so exciting but also
beneath that excitement excitement of
the idea that persons other than a white
male could and should be president
uh was part of the entire drama that why
is it that in the united states of
america only white males could be
president so therefore here i was a
twofer
not only a woman but a black person so
therefore i was representing in a sense
a black person and a female person and
so my campaign in the beginning
was swamped
with a lot of blacks
and women
around me and that's how that got off
the ground but believe you me it was not
easy because when after i made that
announcement and i began now to visit
different parts of the country assemble
a staff and everything it's a real
league of nation staff
hell
broke loose
and the reason hell broke loose because
how dare you
have you forgotten that you are a woman
have you forgotten that you are black
and you
want to be president who's telling you
these things a lot of the black males at
that time had very
negative feelings about my announcement
and a lot of the white males
it was the males
it was the males primarily that gave me
the fit
i could remember so distinctly so many
incidents in which uh
they felt that i was going in the wrong
direction can you think of one incident
and name one name
it's 20 years you know yeah i know it is
20 years
but i know
that in terms of the black males
it was felt i don't want to call one
there because of so many of them that
had the same feeling
uh they really felt that if indeed a
black person is going to make a bid for
the presidency
it should not be a black woman
it should be a black male this whole
machismo thing gets in the way
and not only that the black males were
very annoyed with me
because they were having this big
conference in gary indiana
this black conference where mr hatcher
who was the mayor then of gary and they
were coming together to find a black
person to run for president uh stoke's
name we mentioned all that and shirley
chisholm had jumped the gun
and they
they
they felt that
where does she think she's going she
didn't get our approval
the fact of the matter is i was very
cognizant of the fact
that i would never get their approval
because they would feel that i was crazy
maybe i needed to be placed on a
straight jacket and so i went ahead on
the basis of the fact that there were
citizens in this country
who raised the money
for me to make the bid because these
citizens felt that i had what it takes i
possessed leadership qualities
i had a clear understanding of the
issues
i was a fearless woman
and i was intelligent that was all but
the only thing that bothered a lot of
folks i was black
and
i was a woman how did the women's groups
that existed at the time respond to your
candidacy
it was half and half some of them
responded positively and some did not
but an amazing thing happened to me that
shocked me
i guess for about three years that the
women in the southern part of the
country
responded to my candidacy more sincerely
and truthfully than the women in the
north i can tell you stories of how
women in the south i remember
particularly the state of mississippi
where some of the local women white
women and hispanics lost their jobs
because the white male power structure
kept reminding them
that shirley chisholm was a black this
is the lady it's a black woman
and these women would respond we know
she's a black woman but she has what it
takes to bring about change
women lost their jobs
white women lost their jobs in parts of
mississippi because they will not
pulled back from my candidacy in florida
when i landed in tallahassee the airport
was jammed with white and black women
in the north i found in many instances
that while the northern white women were
saying yes shirley chisholm's a part of
the feminist movement she's been a
leader but while they were giving me
their beautiful rhetoric
they were destroying my slates behind
the scenes
so they were not many of them were not
truthful to even today
many of the white women in the north of
my generation not the younger people who
don't really know me
uh get very annoyed when people ask me
uh
well you were the first woman
who happened to be black to make a
serious debate for the presidency in
terms of going about the country and
participating not the first woman to run
for president but the first woman who
did traditionally what you must do not
talking about uh some of the evil women
that had run for president but they
didn't do what i did it was just us
symbolic and i always say yes but i must
always remind you
that it was primarily the women in the
south
that put me across and god so many women
in new york get very angry but the truth
is the truth
i i was surprised i was very very
surprised at what happened to me in new
york but you must remember too that i
did not make the bid for the presidency
on the basis of new york i made it on
the basis of the floridians and the
minnesotans who said go
how did your campaign play out i know
you campaigned in the primaries and then
you did go to the convention take us
through that process briefly
well while i was campaigning because i i
campaigned in about 20-21 states i think
it was one of his campaign there were
three or four basic things that
i met constantly
i
met constantly
the fact that black men and white men
were very very low in attendance at the
rallies and the meetings where i was
making appearances that was very obvious
to me
secondly
i
ran into divisions
within the particular cities in which
iran
because the black people and the white
people particularly the
feminists were actually having
disagreements
uh because i'm a woman
and the feminist felt this is our
candidate
we brought her in we sponsored her
and then the black people in the
community of course i am black
and so they felt but she's one of us
but in many cases they didn't pay to
bring me in
so there was they were trying to jump on
the bandwagon and the white women would
remind we brought her in so we can
schedule her many times i had to just
hide until they got together
and settled the disagreements and i'll
give you a very funny story i remember
when i went into tallahassee never
forget this as long as i live all these
cars at the airport to meet me they must
have been about oh my god it must be
about 50 cars uh white women black women
black a few black men a few white men
and they it was an exciting time they
had all their placards and everything
and then the plane landed
and i got off the plane with my two
aides
the black community and the white
community rushed to meet me to put me in
a waiting car to take me off to the
rally and while they were taking me
while the white community was taking me
to their car the black community she is
one of us she is a sister and they were
arguing around and i looked over i saw
this tiny white man i don't even think
he was five feet tall and he was
standing and he was grinning and
laughing and he had on his hat
c-h-i-z-u-m for president chisholm for
president and he was like he was in a
world all of his own and i went over to
him i said thank you so much i said
canada can i
get into your car and you take me to the
rally and they will stop fighting and
fussing and they will follow
and he said i don't have a a number one
car i don't i said does it move
he said yes and he was so excited he got
me into the car and off we went and the
moment i got into his car
all of the raucous
uh outbursts stopped and they all jumped
into their cars trying now to follow
that car i'll never forget that as long
as i live which i hadn't met the visions
constantly in that way how many delegate
votes did you get at the convention i
got 158 delegate votes at the convention
and the majority of them came from the
south
it was amazing that mississippi
i got um if i can remember if it's not
exactly it's near there i got about six
of the
12 votes from mississippi
i got about 20 something of the
louisianan votes
i got
a large number i got more votes from the
south and many of the persons that
indicated me shirley
go ahead
make the run you got to have catholics
for change in america and we have to
have catholics for change who are not
shrinking violence so you certainly are
not but you've got to remember don't go
to the south in retrospect if i did not
go to the south i would have fallen
completely flat on my face did you get
prime time television time at the podium
at the convention oh yes oh yes they
gave me opportunity and the ones who
jumped up and screamed the loudest
carried on because that delegation was
seated in the front was george wallace's
alabamian delegation
it was a strange thing because george
was when i was campaigning because you
remember that was the year about 13 of
us were running mcgovern lindsay and a
whole bunch of us and i i remember when
i was campaigning even in florida george
wallace used to tell the folks if you
can't vote for me in the primary don't
vote for those pointy-headed liberals
vote for shirley chaser awards so people
felt that i had entered into a pact with
george wallace and because of that i
lost some floridian votes
but i also called john lindsay to get
out of the race in florida because i was
beating john lindsay in the primary and
john lindsay had a private meeting with
me when i returned to new york he was
mayor at the time and he wanted me to
get he said shirley you're moving into
my vote did everything to get me to
remove myself from the floridian primary
and i remember telling john
john my time has come i've got to do
this i'll never forget that as long as i
live and it caused a kind of uh
our friendship was never as great as it
used to be after i refused to pull out
of that race in florida
but i must tell the world that it was
the south that really took me across and
many of my
friends many people in new york are
angry because they want the world to
feel
that because i am a new yorker and i did
come from new york that they were the
one that pushed me out there while
having nothing is further from the truth
what was your message to the convention
my message for to come the
convention basically was that the time
has come
when we in america can no longer be the
complacent passive
recipients
of whatever the politics of our nation
may decree for us
that the time has come that we must look
at other americans
who have the attributes of leadership
who has a knowledge of the issues
to make a bid in an unequivocal manner
for the presidency of the united states
of america
and i have decided to accept this
challenge and here i am today do as you
will did you ever
were did you ever think you were on a
short list uh to be george mcgovern's
vice presidential no no i never i never
fooled myself you know i people must
have thought surely children really
think she could be president
look i'm fairly intelligent and i was
smart enough to know that i couldn't be
president but somebody has to be a
catalyst for change
when you're attempting to bring about
change in america i've always regarded
myself as a catalyst for change
we're also 20 years in the anniversary
of watergate and i wonder if during
that year you follow the news reports
like everybody else but as an inside
politician
sort did you
see or detect or wonder about any of
these what later came to be known as
dirty tricks occurred
oh yes because i was the victim of
donald segrete out in california
donald's in fact the people in
california called me
donald segreta you know he had
circulated some literature about muskie
and donald segretti is who donald sugury
was one of the tricksters
in the nixon campaign and his job was to
derail the candidacies of the democrats
who were running
and oh he said some awful things about
humphrey and about musky but look at
what he said about shirley chisholm
shirley chisholm
had been released
from a mental institution a few years
ago and it is known
that she uh she rubs feces on the walls
of the rooms
in her home and what
it
i still that the paper at home is yellow
and crumpled how did that
what device did he use to get that
information out throw away
how do you know it was from donald
segretti because
my friends in california sent me all the
leaflets that was put out by
mcdonald's secretary at that time
did not say he did it but as a result of
the watergate hearings and everything it
came out that he did it because it
wasn't only a very negative and
untruthful things that were said about
me which also said about humphrey and
muskie and others but the most slimy
sleazy types of remarks
uh and my friends in california alerted
me to it and later he apologized to all
of us personally not personally but by
the media the newspapers picked it up do
you think those tricks had any effect on
your campaign
no not really
there are some other people what was
jesse jackson doing at the time
that you were running what was his role
in politics
uh jesse jackson never supported me for
the presidency or anything although i
supported him in 84 and 88
been campaigning for him he called on me
so often to do a lot of things but jesse
jackson never never really supported me
for the prayer did you ask for his
support
well at that time you know early in the
game back in 72
and jesse jackson of course was aligned
with the black
power boys that were meeting in gary
indiana trying to stop me he was a part
of that uh machismo group who felt that
the black woman
uh
who didn't consult the brothers
have no business money for president and
i understood that i'm not holding it
against them or anything i understand
why they're they're very uh
they're full of machismo
well why did you run for congress we're
going backwards here we're now back to
1960
sure 68. all right a new a new district
had been created in the borough of
brooklyn giving an opportunity for the
first time for the thousands of black
and hispanic peoples that reside in
brooklyn a chance to send one of their
own to the united states house of
representatives now when that came out
it was felt once again that a black man
should get deceit should run for the
seat and a group of representatives from
community organizations held a
series of interviews with about five of
us who wanted to see
and then they vote after hearing uh the
five of us on the basis of the issues
where we stood our community work and
what have you the overwhelming majority
voted for me although i was a woman and
just sent them up the wall it the men
you know if i have survived if i
survived during those years that i was
moving out politically
uh i could survive anything
i cried many nights because i was
misinterpreted she wanted to take things
away from the black man she's one just
gonna divide the black men from the
black women all of this crazy stuff that
was coming off the wall but i didn't let
it affect me that much because i
understood our history i understood why
the men would feel this way
they would feel this way because
actually they felt the time had come for
black men it was black men's term and
nobody should get in the way including
black women so i understood that
and uh but it was very hurting
many of the things that they said about
me many of the misunderstandings and
many of the misinterpretations of my
actions they gave the feeling that i was
some kind of a horrible little monster
what did they say
uh they said that she has no right to be
running for the congress because if
indeed a black person is going to the
congress
it should be a male were there personal
attacks
there were some personal attacks not
many but most of them would just mail
this mail thing a little bit well um you
ran against james farmer oh yes was that
in the general or the primary no that
was in the general election so he was
the reason he was the republican he was
the republican and he is he was what at
that time
he was the republican but i mean he had
a national reputation oh yeah he was the
leader of core the congress on racial
equality here was james farmer a a
bright articulate man with a beautiful
voice and he was giving everyone the
impression that he could mow down
shirley chisholm did he live in the
district he did not live in the district
he lived in new york and we found out
they you know they i think they looked
at me and they said oh little school
teacher what does she know
uh but uh we really had a panel truck
going across the manhattan bridge
watching him leave his home in lower
manhattan coming into brooklyn every day
to campaign for the congressional seat
why didn't he go up against adam clayton
paulo one of those no but he wanted that
newly created seat in brooklyn so i
developed the three things that helped
me i think to uh to eventually win
number one he was not a resident of
brooklyn
he had i understood he had uh secured a
little room just for the purposes of
addressing what have you
uh number two
he didn't realize how fluent in spanish
i was
and so when we went into hispanic
heritage well we had a pretty large
spanish area i would speak in english
and then i would speak in spanish the
first time james farmer heard me speak
spanish i see his mouth opening right
now i was a little bit late he wanted to
know what else have you got under that
hat of yours i mean he just couldn't get
over that and then thirdly
james got to the point where this
machismo thing was so strong with black
men during that time he got to the point
where every morning when the people
would be going to work he had these uh
these viral muscular-looking young black
men on sound trucks at about four or
five subway stations giving out his
literature and the drums beating send a
man to the house and this kind of thing
going on and i began to uh to feel badly
about this i said oh no don't feel badly
accept the challenge
i knew and i always had a feeling there
are more women in the district than men
so i went down to the board of elections
with a couple of persons and checked the
roles
2.7 women to one man in the district and
i went back to my headquarters and i
sent out a call to the women leaders in
the district black
white
italian jews i said we have to go to war
that was it
and that we mobilized by how much did
you win
three to one
mobilized then you go to washington
and tell the story of your committee
assignment
[Laughter]
well when i got to washington
it was understood that freshmen should
be seen and not heard you accept
whatever committee assignment the
committee on committees give you they
placed me on an agriculture committee
some committee on forestry in rural
villages and the more i thought about
the more angry i became because for so
many years the minority persons in
brooklyn new york never had a
representative they come from a a city
area and they're going to put the first
representative on a committee dealing
with rural forestry and villages and the
more i thought about it no this is
madness i spoke with some of the
congressmen and i told them how i felt
they said surely you've got to
understand become you'll get your
committee assignment eventually but you
have to take the assignment that the
committee gives you and the men told me
this is what angered me they said you
are right
but you shouldn't rock the boat and i
spoke with brock adams brock adams i
must say was the first white congressman
that befriended me and looked out for me
i'll never forget that what's he doing
now brock adams now you know he was the
secretary of transportation in the car
the cabinet and now he uh i don't know
why you don't because he's no longer in
congress because of a series of
misadventures that uh be took him
but um
i told brock i told brock what i was
going to do i was going to put uh an
amendment in to remove my name from the
forestry and uh rural villages committee
and asked for another assignment that
has a little bit more relevancy to the
district brock said
surely you can't you
you can do it but you know you're
committing
political suicide before you get started
i've heard that phrase about 300 times
in my political life committing
political suicide so i have to do it so
anyhow the word got out shirley chisholm
is going to challenge the speaker she's
going to challenge the chairperson of
the committee on committee who was a
speaker at that time uh oh o'hara from
massachusetts uh what's his name oh uh
mccormick mccormick what is that okay
why did i say oh howard mccormack john
mccormack john mccormick was the speaker
at that time so and little mills was the
chairman of the committee on committees
that makes the assignments so i felt now
the word had gotten out it leaked out
that shirley chisholm
was going to cause a little raucous i
mean it makes it a big thing out of
nothing
so i called the speaker i wanted to be
fair i didn't want to think that i came
from the state legislation only to upset
the sacrifice tradition of the united
states house of representatives so i
called to speak and i told the speaker
mr speaker i just want you to know that
tomorrow when the democratic caucus
meets
i am going to ask for
a change of committee assignment because
it does not make sense for me to be
sitting even for two years on a
committee that has absolutely no
relevancy even if they had put me on the
committee that dealt with hot lunch
programs or what have you it might be a
little bit more sense but forestry i
don't know what we would for i mean what
foolishness is this so i said to the per
the uh chair to the speaker
uh i forgot i was speaking to the
speaker i was so
uh upset
i said mr speaker i'm going to have to
do my thing that was a favorite phrase
at that time
and the speaker said to me you're going
to have to do what
i said oh excuse me mr speaker i'm going
to have to do that which i have to do
and
go with it he said you know you'll be
beaten down i'll take the chance but he
didn't like i can tell by the tone of
his voice she'll make a long story short
that day a lot of the men don't usually
come to democratic caucus the caucus
almost had 100 attendance the balcony
was filled with the reports because they
heard what i was going to do so i came
in but they had made a plan and that
plan was
when shirley chisholm
desires to be recognized in the caucus
four or five men
who had seniority over me was to raise
their hand and the speaker from the days
would recognize them and after a while
shirley chisholm would get tired jumping
up and down like a jackrabbit they
thought nobody got scared they didn't
know me they don't know what kind of
person so after i i found myself going
up and down and i know they could see me
because i'm very highly visible
i decided to do one thing
i decided i was so mad i had some notes
i was going to use i
put the notes in my seat
and i walked down without the speaker
calling right down to the well of the
house and the men in anything for for as
a diversionary tactic the men saying go
to the shirley go to the shirt and the
old speaker hitting the gavel there'll
be order in this house
and you know the funniest thing happened
after i got down to develop the house
i suddenly became frightened what am i
going to do
well i stood there and the speaker i
didn't know the old speaker could hop
off the day so quickly he hopped off the
days he kind of side looked at me and he
ran over to wilbur mills and they put
their heads together and whatever it was
the speaker came back and he recognized
wilbur mills and i'm standing right
there in the middle of the house and
willa mills said with these centauri any
stuntorium tones wanting to frighten and
harass me now for what purpose does the
gentle woman from the county of kings in
the borough of brooklyn the great empire
state of new york stand in the middle of
the house
[Laughter]
and i thought when he did that that by
using those tones because he had a deep
voice anyhow that i would run out of the
realm of the house
and i said
as calm as i knew how to
mr chairman
for the past 35 minutes i have been
attempting to gain recognition
and i'm a very highly visible person in
this house of representatives and for
whatever your reasons may be
the speaker has not recognized me so i
thought the best thing to do was to come
to the well of the house because i have
something very important to say
said the gentle woman from the borough
of brooklyn the empire state of new york
will have five minutes
and i spoke out and i say it seems that
all of you just knew that a true a tree
grows in brooklyn
but i want you to know that i am asking
i'm putting an amendment to ask for a
different assignment an assignment a
committee assignment that has a little
bit more relevancy to the district that
i represent not a subcommittee on
fostering rural villages
surprisingly enough nobody had ever done
this before in the house i was a bad
child but you know something they went
back they had a meeting and they did
give me a committee something had a
little bit more relevancy to the
district because at least i was placed
on the veterans affairs committee more
veterans in the district than foreign
trees
and that's how that and after i did that
when others came in
and they started to put them in crazy
committees they would speak up whether
or not they got the assignment
and they later told me
that they wanted
to make sure that they would keep me
quiet and keep me hidden before i
started blossoming in the house and they
were shocked when i told them i knew
that's what you all were trying to do
but now you know the kind of person i am
how did you who was your closest
leadership ally in the house in those
days
who did you look to did you have a
mentor or did you even need one
no i didn't have a mentor as such
because even though the gentleman
it was funny about the house of
representatives in those days
the democrats
they admired me and they liked my
spunkiness and my
uh my feisty spirit but i think they
were a little bit afraid to be too
closely allied with me because they knew
that the speaker didn't look on me too
kindly because i was
rebellious in terms of not accepting
assignments that didn't make sense and
of course because of the patronage
system going to the air shows and all of
this they wanted to be sure that they'll
get hit first so i remember i remember
one day i was walking down the hall
uh with two of the congresspersons and
the speaker i was just getting together
his list of those persons who will go to
the great air show you know there's a
great thing in the springtime up there
on the hill to paris yes
and uh they were talking with me and all
of a sudden both of them disappeared
from me they were because the speaker
was coming down the hall and they didn't
want the speaker to to to really feel
that they were that close to me it was a
strange thing because those guys live on
the basis of getting their little tick
[ __ ] in their little person so you can
imagine i was in the house i i didn't go
i didn't go on junkies because i
wouldn't behave myself and both speakers
uh
uh tiffany neil later you know they used
to always tell me you know you'd
just don't know what to do with you
don't you one time they asked me well
don't you want to go to the airstrike
and i told them straight if i want to go
to years or i could pay my fear and they
looked at me you know because this is
this doesn't happen i didn't realize it
now until really some
some
18 16 18 years later
how
how
progressive i was
how and why the gentleman and the people
in politics looked at me the way they
did because i did things that you were
not supposed to do but in the process of
doing them i opened up new approaches
but i paid for it in terms of not
getting all the nice perks and
everything but that didn't bother me i
didn't go there to get perps
why did you quit
i quit because from the very inception
of my political career when i was even
in the new york state legislature and i
still have it at home i said
from the inception of my political
career never do i intend to spend all of
my creative and productive years in the
political arena i never intended to be
dragged out in an oxygen tent or
actually dying and what have you and
what also supplemented my leaving was
that the reagan administration had come
in and i saw so many things that we had
done during the civil rights movement
and what have you just beginning to fade
away before my eyes and my face
and i also saw that the people back in
my own district were taking it out on me
because i could no longer deliver like i
used to be able to deliver under the
card or administration and what have you
and so i decided this was the propitious
moment then for me to leave and go out
and do other things because of the fact
that i knew from the inception of my
floor i didn't intend to spend all my
adult life in politics what did you go
to do
i became
a visiting professor i do a lot of
visiting professorships all over this
country i love the young people
and so i conduct a lot of seminars i do
a lot of speech writing for politicians
you'd be surprised some of them i do
speech writing for well who are you
going to tell us no i will not i can't
but i want to ask you a few more things
about congress uh what would you change
about congress to make it more effective
i would change the fact i would change
this basically i do not think that the
congress of the united states is
representative of the populations that
make up this country
this country is a multifaceted
multi-racial uh
multi-ethnic
uh land how can you change your
constitution by right no i i'm not even
talking about changing the constitution
i'm talking about what's happening now
more women getting out there and running
and winning
more hispanics and african-americans
accepting the challenge it doesn't mean
that you will necessarily
win but you got to have the guts and the
courage of your convictions to help to
bring about change
through your own actions not change
through rhetoric isn't that happening
now it's happening now it's almost it's
a wonderful thing i'm so glad that 20
years
later that i have lived to to really see
what is happening and of course for the
year 1992 the impetus to making the
women feel they had to get go out there
is when they looked on at the days of
that herring the hill thomas hearings
and so all these white males making
these determinations about an issue that
affected women and no woman having a
voice that i think that was the turning
point for this year that let me say the
heck with this we've got to get out
there and start uh running whether or
not we win we've got to accept the
challenge had you been on the senate
judiciary committee what do you think
would have happened
oh i don't i probably would not have
been able to have the to get the votes
but i certainly would have spoken out
about the way in which they were
questioning miss hill i did not like it
for one moment
and i saw
you know orrin hatch and this other guy
from wyoming uh the face
particularly those two and then when the
ireland's all respective his
prosecutorial tone
after oh
i
well
it's a good thing i wasn't under
committee because they probably have to
ask somebody to take me out
you watched all that weekend i'll take
it oh gosh i ate nothing but frankfurt's
because i couldn't take my eye off the
screen to make a meal i just had to i
couldn't believe it's like a fairy story
to me that was happening it wasn't that
the fact that they didn't have to do
what they felt they had to do because
politics is so darn partisan the
republicans had made their minds up they
had to get clarence thomas on the bench
and the democrats had made had made
their minds up that they had to make
sure he didn't get on the bench so
politics being what it is everybody
engages in all kinds of tricks and what
have you understood that but it was not
what they were doing especially how they
were doing it what they were doing to
that woman it
it just did something to me
one of the big questions is do you
believe him or her
it's hard because neither one of us were
there we don't know what really happened
do you have a joint you have a feeling
in your gut
i have a feeling that
it there is something on both sides of
that issue and i don't choose to go into
that there's something on both sides of
that issue it doesn't have anything to
do with politics that's all i want to
say
um
what how do you think
black leadership would have evolved had
martin luther king remained alive
i think if nothing else martin luther
king was the one black leader in this
country in this era
that had the uh the uncanny ability and
skills
and
articulation to
issue a call to bring the black leaders
together
the majority of black leaders together
there's no one today that can really
bring all of the black leaders together
whether they're conservatively oriented
leaders progressives or what have you
and martin luther would have outlined
for us
he was given some kind of agenda of
where he think we ought to be going on
what happened doesn't necessarily mean
that we would have accepted it but he
commanded the respect
he had the integrity
and the principles which a lot of
leaders don't have today
there's not integrity
there's not the
principles there's a lot of political
expediency that goes on
it doesn't emanate from the heart it's
what you can get out of it or what have
you and i think
that had martin luther king been alive
today
that we may not have found ourselves in
a kind of
position in which there there doesn't
seem any longer to be any unanimity of
purpose
uh amongst the black leaders pertaining
to an agenda for the future for our
people that is very troubling to me
how much longer do you think that race
will be a central issue
in american public affairs it will
always be a central issue
racism this country was founded in
racism
it is the bugaboo of america which has
rendered america so vulnerable to the
attacks of her opponents both within
this country
and without this country you must
remember when the basic document of this
land was written
black folks were only counted as
three-fifths of a person it's only until
the passage of the 13th 40th and 15th
amendment that we were finally
five-fifths of a person if the country
was born and bred in racism i don't
really believe that we'll ever really
eradicate racism in america however i
must say honestly that they have been
improvements down through the years god
help us if we didn't have any but they
have been improvements and right now at
this point in time i sometimes feel
that we're back in the 1950s as i
traveled throughout the country once
again and i see what is happening
sometimes i think we're back in the
1950s because there has been an erosion
of so many of the gains that
we made
i don't think we could ever get rid of
racism in america i'm sorry to say but
my gut tells me that i hope i'm wrong
but that's the way i feel at this moment
have you ever thought of yourself as a
victim
of racism
well i've used the word victim because
as you know there's a lot of discussion
about
uh the victim mentality of minorities
not necessarily blacks but and that
there's the criticism that black
leadership encourages the sense of
victimization because then that provides
a rationale for
seeking help from the government
and i wonder if you accept that
or is there another way to go
no i i i don't see it that they
at all
i have to put it in this kind of
perspective i have to put in the fact
that
whatever
these leaders have been able to utilize
that has worked in some way
and it has redounded
to the benefit of african-american
people and it was successful
that they feel in many instances this is
the way they should always go
they're not very experimental
they're not very creative in terms of
looking at new ways of doing things
you're always not only black white
leaders you always become a little bit
uh satisfied and complacent if you found
something that has worked even if it is
no longer appropriate for the times in
which we are living i think it's more a
kind of a frailty of human nature that
does this kind of thing and that's why
even today everybody's kind of uh
upset and worried about the fact
that for example a ross perot is out
here who is he i mean he's not a
democrat or he's not a republican or
whatever and yet everybody's falling
behind him you know you're going away
from tradition uh about ross in his own
strange way he's being creative if i
could say that and everybody's
focusing on ross instead of focusing on
the agendas that will make american
people who have become alienated and
cynical about the traditional ways of
doing things return they're too busy
focusing on mr perrault instead of
correcting the inequities and the
grievances that the american people have
been indicating for some quite some time
in america this is gone this year in my
humble opinion
is going to be a bloodless
mini
political revolution i see it
i see it coming i see it it's going to
be some convention both at the
republican party
convention and the democratic party
convention i know where all of i speak
well why then
if that's so
why do you think that the republican
convention will be something other than
just a renomination of the president and
the vice president i think that because
surprisingly enough
a large number
of republican women and some of my best
friends are republicans
a large number of republican women
are going to the convention saying
they're not going to take this
anti-abortion
issue i'm not going to use the word they
use
anymore you're going to raise it on the
floor
uh i could see that your public
convention
a kind of
outburst and i put the word out burst in
quotation marks around
that whole abortion issue that's how i
see it at the republican
convention it's going to come that way
at the democratic convention
when you know that
in the city of new york it's already
been indicated that you're going to have
all kinds of delegations out there in
the streets first of all they've got to
make sure they have a place where they
can keep them away
you're going to have
the pro-abortion forces the pro-choice
forces the homeless say they're
building their own tent out there
you're going to have
the gay community saying that
neither republicans are the democrats
are paying attention to our issues and
because new york is a very overt
outspoken place where anything and
everything goes
i see
and i i see but i also hope that that
convention does not come about like the
one in 1968
in chicago where he had all of these
different groups out there
rebelling and all the people in america
could see on the screen
where the policeman
i i i'm very concerned
well in the time remaining
you retired from politics in 82 and you
went into teaching
what have you been teaching
i've been teaching
the role of women in america
i've been teaching the history of black
women
in america
i've been teaching congress
power
politics
and my classes are very unusual in that
i do not
get it before the class
and pontificate
i
conduct a class in terms of my
experiences
give them some basic premises pertaining
to all three of these areas and then
there's a constant dialogue going on in
the class between myself and the
students
and many of the
supervisors
and persons in higher education who have
witnessed my classes have made me feel
very proud they said your classes are
the most exciting life classes we have
ever seen the students in fact wherever
i go the students and the professors
asked me to come back but i have not
gone back to many of them because i want
to do this in as many universities as i
can
as of now i speak to you
i have been
in over
225 universities and colleges of this
country during the past 25 years of my
life they've given to me the greatest
kinds of experiences
i love young people
and i don't feel that we spend enough
time with them
and so at this stage of my life i
consider myself a states woman
i consider myself a mentor
and i consider myself a person who's had
the opportunity to be able to pass on to
the next generation
to benefit whatever benefit they can get
out of the
experiences i have had in this country
well how do you explain all the press
reports and surveys that show voter
participation of young people way down
and even interest weighed down there's a
reason for it because they've been
listening to all this rhetoric they've
been listening to the fact that the
peace dividend will come back to the
people of this country and they
and they wouldn't have to worry about
whether or not they're going to have to
complete their four-year college
education these kids i talk with them
they're frightened to death as to
whether or not they're going to be able
to complete their education if they're
already in college or whether or not
they're going to be able to have the
opportunity to go to college since the
tuition rates are so high uh they have
been victims of hearing their parents
and their grandparents talk about
abstain korea gate billy gate the iran
country
they become cynical like a lot of the
adults you say who needs it your own
students who you say are rather engaged
and intellectually alive what do you
think they go out of your classrooms and
vote and become active citizens oh a lot
of them do
a lot of them do but it's a it's an
amazing thing that they refuse this is
very interesting to me
a disproportionate number of them do not
register
as democrats
or republicans they're registered as
independents and so when i have talked
with them in private conversations
well you know there's some basic
premises
in a democratic philosophy politically
as you've known in america and in a
republican philosophy politically as
you've known why don't you you can make
a choice
uh-uh
because we are not interested in mr
chisholm and the party for philosophy
necessary we want to look at the person
what the person's pattern of behavior
will indicate to us they're not as hung
up on
traditional parties as we older folk are
i'm finding that out they're not as hung
up on the party structure as we are
how old are you i'm 67 years of age how
old do you feel i feel like 37
what are your plans for the future
i live my life now one day
at a time i have no specific plans since
my husband passed away
five years ago people really came back
to me and said surely we need
that
righteous voice of indignation out there
come back and let our your voice be
heard more and run again for something
said my time has passed i would rather
train and mentor and help younger blacks
and younger women who are coming along
perfectly contented with the life that
i'm leading at this point
it's probably early for me to ask this
of a 37 year old woman but
because
but because of
i think you'll get it what would you
like
what would you like that makes me older
than you yeah
what would you like for your epitaph
that's interesting you should ask me
that
i really give that a great little
thought i would like i don't want to be
i don't want to be necessarily known as
the first african-american woman to be
elected to congress
or the first female
who happened to be african-american to
be elected i would rather like to be
my episode i would have to read shirley
chisholm
a catalyst for change
in the 20th century
who happened
to be
an african-american female
i want to be known as
a catalyst for change because that's how
i regard myself
shirley chisholm thank you very much
certainly thank you
[Music]
c-span's american profile conversations
highlight the lives and careers of
political and business leaders
the programming aims to provide our
viewers with a better understanding of
the individual behind the public persona
next on c-span we continue our american
profile conversations with a look at the
life of ambassador edward perkins
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]